[Music]
so with the king here we go baby
at Jacobs vs. Canelo this is a fight I
thought I'd never see I thought it it
never happened why because I felt that a
canola oil didn't have heart I felt that
Jacobs didn't have a champ
what whoa what happened
well how does fight King in the past
it's not by normal circumstances you see
the zone went out that perches both for
these fighters now on a surface I said
to myself man I didn't understand why
Canelo went over there yeah they gave
him a bag and the amount of money is
comparable to what he would have made
other places during the fall of HBO
Canelo and a lot of the top fighters
that fought on that promotional cause
were left in limbo so we thought that
Eddie Hearn will try to do something
with match game
that's his promotional house match game
services but he aligns itself with the
zone which is the promotional arm of
match game and they actually put on the
fights like Showtime but they're
separate entities that bring their wares
over there and that fighters and have
them be promoted by that car so it's
just like having financial back and
that's all I understand is being backed
by big bank instead of doing it by
yourself okay so Eddie Hearn has aligned
himself with the zone which was a
startup so Eddie Hearn going in had
Joshua all right so you know he had a
big heart but he didn't have the little
guys and when Canelo signed with his own
I'm like okay now that I love Gennady
golovkin left out and a lot of the
middle weights which fights for al
Heyman
at the PBC now the owl Haman PBC has
been ruling it they've been having a
good time these guys has been fighting
himself the Walter wheat division is lit
he has a lot of middleweights
he has all the lighter weights pretty
much sold up all right it's very few and
far between free agents
so when Canelo signed over there it was
like wow you know and a couple of other
fighters signed over there like I'm dry
day and stuff like that so now when then
you Jacob signed over there
you said Wow hello this possibility is
for good fights and then just recently
triple G signed over there so you say
the zone has three of the top drawing
middle weights right now to get to this
fight you're looking at age you're
looking at it versus experience you're
looking at speed versus combinations
you're looking at a whole bunch of
things now on a surface these guys will
want you to believe that is white versus
black well actually Mexican versus black
on the surface these guys would like you
to believe that there is a such thing as
Mexican fighting and african-american
fighting styles wise all that is hogwash
all that is crap you know that's not
something that I want you to focus on
but I want you to focus on as the
resumes of these fighters right so
you're looking at the resumes of these
fighters and you're gonna say Canelo
actually really has fought this the best
degeneration yeah he lost to me weather
which I thought was a clear loss
he fought Al and Ellora which I thought
was a loss um he for triple G which I
felt that uh one of those fights could
have been a draw and the next fight I
thought he outclassed triple G in such a
fashion didn't make any sense Daniel
Jacobs everybody wanted to Hawking in on
him overcoming cancer it's a great story
it's a great selling point it pulls on
hard stream
but does that translate into the ring
we're not here for the show we're not
here for oh you know did he sell this
much biscuits and Girl Scout cookies and
all this other we don't care about that
we want to know what this fighter does
Danny Jacobs gets down with the best of
them before he was sidelined with cancer
he was dynamite Danny Jacobs they were
comparing him to the way he moved little
Mike Tyson he was going out knocking
people out till he got knocked out in
the first round he got knocked out in
the first round came out cold listen
there's no excuses for anything of that
nature when it comes to a fighter but I
honestly believe that he is reading his
own press clippings I don't believe that
he had a good nutritional plan I don't
believe that he is training properly you
know cancer has made him reassess all of
that stuff you know um
not trying to make cancer a talking
point but again his turnaround is 180
all right a lot of you guys will say 360
360 means you turn around came back to
the right same spot 180 is the only turn
all right so he did a 180 nutritional
training everything has definitely been
above boys never wavered when it came to
his trainer his head coach and these
things are necessary and understanding a
fighter his mindset do you stay with
what got you here
Canelo's the same way he stayed with
what got him there and what got him
there is a slew of fights where he has
racked up experience on such a high
level you can only say that second to
Floyd Mayweather that's high praise
Canelo is that guy who has been in there
with the best of them Mikoto Sugar Shane
Mosley a lot of Fighters you never
thought that he would get in the ring
with triple Gene nobody ever thought
that would happen now remember I don't
do fights I don't talk about fights
until the fighters actually hit that
scale so both fighters weighed in at a
ready 160 both right uh Canelo was 159
Jacobs was 160 either but see the thing
work anomaly is he pulls the eight sides
bs floyd used to do it always weight
rehydration Clauses weight limit type of
things things to tip the scale and a
favor of the smaller fighter which is
Canelo so it was a rehydration clause
that Jacobs could not come in the day
after the official winged more more than
170 we know the history with Jacobs he
can care less about your rehydration
clause or making weight day of the fight
why he has a preparation method that he
is not going to let being peed by such
politics if it's not gonna cancel the
fight you best believe he's gonna be
overweight that night that's a fact so
guess what happens Jacobs didn't make
the second Oh weight limit which was 170
Jacobs came in 170 3.4 was 74 pounds I
expect him tonight to be at least 178
179 going into that ring I expect Canelo
to he came in at 169 I expect Canelo to
come in topped off tops 170 tops alright
so you're gonna say Daniel Jacobs was
gonna have a weight advantage he's gonna
be rehydrated properly hopefully at the
end a despite we
don't have a case where somebody tested
positive for tainted meat pause all
right so you got youth on canelo side
you got boxing ability on Jacob side not
by much because you know Canelo throws
punches in bunches for those punches and
combinations you guys believe he's
trying to rip that combination and
trying to fade you to the left hook to
the body then you Jacobs have been
pretty solid to the body ever since the
first round knockout
he's been looked at as having some type
of weak chin he stood up to test of time
two punches um when he fought uh Peter
Quillin kid chocolate he not kid
chocolate out cold flat back to banging
banging um Danny Jacobs style footwork
got to go with Danny Jacobs chin got to
go Canelo boxing experience got to go to
Neville ring generalship gotta go Jacobs
so you say coming into this fight this
but this is a fifty-fifty fight this is
a pretty much even fight this is a fight
where you know you can throw a coin in
the air wherever it lands on he can win
that night ace in the hole for Canelo
Oscar De La Hoya that's the ace in a
hole because Oscar De La Hoya and the
zone has invested a huge amount of money
in Canelo if you don't think that plays
a role in this
then you're fooling yourself alright is
the reason why you sign with big plays
there's a reason why you understand when
you're big home he comes in you good
you walk different you move different
without the big homie some dos don't
really move the same way Daniel Jacobs
thinking he's on his own too
mad corners fight
I only believed that Daniel Jacobs can
win one way if he wins that decision you
know that
Dagny impossible as we saw he number was
every damn round the Floyd Mayweather
and one judge had it going for Canelo
I'm gonna split some some some while out
stupidness all right so that lets you
know the back and the boy has he's the
money man in this fight going to do a
decision
I give Jacobs a 20% chance Canelo 80%
chance if there is a knockout the
knockout will be at the hands of Daniel
Jacobs because he has a devastating
right hand
I'm telling you devastating see the
thing with Jacobs is he's ambidextrous
South Pole Orthodox the boy will switch
on the fly the common fighter that they
have is triple G so you're gonna look at
that and you're gonna say well the way
that he fought triple G and a way to
connect for triple G you could come to
some type of synapses and thinking that
the fight will play out in this manner
it won't different fights different
types it won't just because ABC doesn't
mean that B B's D none of that stuff
matters the only thing that matters is
these guys actually getting it on right
now when they're in that ring Jacobs see
this is the problem you got the tale of
two Jacobs you got the knockout Jacob
and you got the jab jab boxing Jacob
when the rounds win the rounds if he
listens to his coach and he plays that
crap I'm telling you right now Jacobs is
going to lose the fight from wild one
Jacobs needs to jump on Canelo and polls
his size and pulls his length all right
and that's the main thing box from your
position never give up your distance now
for Canelo to win Canelo needs to slip
the jab and shoot right hands and make
sure you dig to Jacobs body remove his
legs make um a stationary opponent so
that you can get off your combinations
fight is gonna play out as such for at
least three to four rounds they're gonna
be feeling each other out
Jacob can not and should not come out
cautionary at all
he must be dominant from round one he
must impose his will connect Canelo will
not allow that to happen as we can see
from the weigh-in
where these guys were completely
wagering that's what I saw so - wait
drain for fighters - absolutely drained
out fighters that man I'm so over this
sport and this breaking down a fighter
before the fight they can make this wait
and then whoever rehydrates the best has
the best chance of winning we're not
really seeing these fighters at their
best at their peak unless they're
fighting at their absolute best weight
you understand so again back to the
scenario in the ring
I see Canelo won in the late rounds
I see Jacobs win in the early rounds I
see Canelo winning by a split decision
would it be deserved I don't know all I
know is this we got a fight that we
shouldn't be getting we got a fight that
should not be happening and this fight
is happening because both combatants in
the ring wants to prove who is the best
at middleweight if Daniel Jacobs wins
this fight he's fighting Canelo again
even if he knocks Canelo out in the
first second third round which is a high
possibility
[Music]
if Canelo wins this fight he's not
fighting him again
Jacobs will have to go through Andrade
to get that belt to put itself back in
position triple G is the odd man out
because Canelo already said I'm not
fighting you unless you got a belt
brother you're gonna have to get out and
prove yourself and triple G's next fight
fighting some guy named rolls I didn't
even look at the fight tape on rolls you
can roll itself out of here with all
that my prediction for the fight Canelo
by split decision
conventional logic tells you the guy
with the most experience and a youthful
guy who throws more combinations can win
a decision not the matter that this guy
is actually the big a side to the card
and it's the promotional draw this is
combat talk with the king catch a set
ILP tomorrow we go over to fight see if
I was right like final subscribe leave
comments down in the bottom so I can get
back at you come on guys let's keep
fighting a lot
[Music]